[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast after dark it is after dark
somewhere i know you're going to tell me
it's not after dark in fact it's many
many hours till dark but it is much
later than we usually do this
if it were december it would be after
dark now at this time of day if it were
december i believe that is the
subjunctive tense it might be i think it
is i was never good at the naming of the
tenses neither was i except in this
moment i may have shined we are brett
weinstein and heather heing and we are
here with episode you got this 121
yes which is not divisible by seven even
though some part of me wants it to be
seven yeah
right right but it's not prime right
right why does seven come up
because of 21.
um yeah
also because of the bible where it shows
up regularly and i think i can make a
strong argument that the length of the
week is an adaptation but another time
okay yep yeah anything else well let's
see oh yes it is
it is five o'clock one-sixth of a time
zone to our east am i right about that
one-sixth of a time zone to our east uh
yeah less even by this time because we
got an even later start that we were
meaning to our producer was otherwise
engaged it seems that he was a
productively engaged which you would
expect from a producer
a fair point and uh we will uh we will
come back with more news of that at a
later time uh for now yes let us let us
embark stop the dithering
is that what we're doing i thought you
were going to tell me that that's not
how time zones work because of course
that's not how time zones work but yet
at this point in the day you're willing
to go along it's not how time zones work
but i'm sure someone who is concerned
about whether or not it's time for them
to have a drink does the math that way
right let's put it to this way the
question of is it five o'clock there
already is dicier than it's almost five
here
yeah yeah
uh that was more dithering wasn't it i
think so yeah
okay uh we are going to talk about
um
totalitarianism
well sure it's saturday and um
and uh
a little bit about hannah rent and uh
alexander suljanison and the things that
live on our ceiling according to our
dear tabby fairfax
and for those
listening and not watching that won't
make any sense but um we are going to
talk a little bit apparently about the
together trial
which was finally published that the one
of the arms was finally published this
week after it was in fact kind of half
announced back
last summer
and
um let's see we've got a we've got a few
other things to talk about um oh as i
wanted to get to last week but we were
too busy explaining what a woman is
we have a there's an op-ed published in
bmj
calling for the need for evidence-based
medicine so in light of
uh things like the other trial i think
it's a good moment to go there yeah
actually
so i don't know in what order we're
going to we're going to do that but
let's do our announcements first we
learned this week that the
hunter-gatherers guide the 21st century
our book that was published
six months ago and is continuing to sell
very well in english
is continuing to the translation rights
continue to be sold in other languages
but the spanish language version is
going to be on sale as of june i think
it was first at least early june
i actually may be conflating two
publication dates now sometime in june
and uh it is the pre-sales are available
on amazon it's got a cool
totally different cover you can show it
here if you want to zach
but you don't have to so i know don't
because i need my computer back now so
um never mind um
don't show it it's actually the more i
think of it the cleverer that cover
seems to me but
that was one of the covers that we um
rejected from our english language
version right but it's uh it's cool yeah
yes you should give me that your father
is talking about yes right yes this will
no doubt not satisfy the people just
listening as much as the people why
don't you explain watching well it is a
uh like a trident
um with a
uh an arrow as the middle fork of the
trident and something usb symbol-ish
symbolizing the hyper novelty of the
moment and also suggesting phylogeny and
one lineage going forward into the
future while others have dead ended at a
square in a circle which raises
questions about familiar relations but
it's it's deep well i i don't i don't
get usb from this at all i get i
i get the phylogenetic tree
and uh the
uh the archaic technology combined with
you know something modern but um i did
not i did not see the usb association
usb yeah yeah
yeah so uh it's cool it's it's it's cool
and you know the british
cover has a different uh a a different
look and i'm just talking here until i
can get my computer back so i can know
what i'm supposed to say next because
we're in that part of the show where i
just i'm supposed to have my notes and
it's not working i'm going to have to
there we go um
so
um the french version's also going to be
published around the same time
we are are we we're live on odyssey
right zach
okay we are live on odyssey and youtube
and the chat is live on odyssey and uh
we will after this first hour of the
show be doing a live q a we encourage
you to ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
we are we always answer one question
from our discord community which you can
get access to by joining either of us at
either of our patreons
this morning you had one of your patreon
conversations fantastic conversation
with the coalition of the reasonable
yeah well you would you would hope
well no you would expect them to be
reasonable but they are well beyond that
oh yes that's the lowest that's the low
bar that's the bar for entry that is the
bar for entry but uh yes they routinely
exceed
that limit and you have another and you
have another conversation tomorrow
tomorrow and i can say very little about
how that will go other than history
suggests it will also be excellent
that's excellent that that is terrific
let's see um on my substitute this week
on natural selections i published a uh
piece with a similar title to what we
talked about on the podcast last week i
think we titled the podcast
what is a woman
and my piece was i'm a woman subtitle
and a biologist so i went there um if
you're looking for that kind of thinking
in writing you can go to
naturalselections.substack.com
and boy there's just so many more
announcements but we're a little bit uh
discombobulated this week i've always
wondered about this word it implies that
we were combobulated earlier right and i
remember i never i can recall never
being
combobulated or populated right nor does
anybody say that they are combobulated
when they intend to convey that they've
got it all under control their ducks are
in a row
yeah and come i mean even just bobulated
like you know you haven't even come
together around it yet you're just
simply
your populated oh it's a sarah star
thing isn't it i don't know what's that
uh that it's the fundamental nature of
the thing
right as opposed to a temporary state of
the thing that's the distinction you're
drawing i believe is sarah star a person
no
right they're differential usage okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a moment out
did our producer also hear sarah stark
so technically this is not a failure for
you to recognize the spanish
construction and relevance of the whole
thing and therefore you can remain as
our translator into spanish for the book
which i of course am not because i've
never made such claims at all in any way
but i don't understand now that i know
what you're trying to say serra versus
estar what the connection to
populated would be here because you were
suggesting that bobulated could just
simply be how you are rather than at
this moment i'm bobulated no that's not
what i was suggesting i was suggesting
you could have a state of being
populated but that is lesser than being
combabulated in which you've come
together with your various relationships
may just be a reversal to the state of
bibulation at what rate are people
dropping off the viewership of the
podcast
so
parser with
usb yeah
oh the whole thing is the usb symbol
yeah oh i didn't i wow yeah i totally
didn't get that that's great very
excellent okay it does not
it should as the usb symbol connote the
repeated flipping of the
chords to try and survive
yeah
um
awesome okay uh let's just
let's do our let's do our ads let's do
that shall we do that yeah okay we have
three ads this week as we often do we
are grateful to our sponsors for helping
giving give us some
uh some independence and some freedom
and we have two sponsors this week that
we have come to you with before you will
recognize them but our first is brand
new to us it is eight sleep
eat sleep is new to us as i just said
now i'm reading the script okay
we are very excited to know
she is so seamless and we are very
excited to know about them and to have
their support good sleep is a game
changer as we discuss in the sleep
chapter of hunter gatherer's guide
intelligent life that found its way to
earth might be surprised by a lot of
what it found on our planet but not by
the fact of sleep or dreams
sleep provides as we argue in the sleep
chapter
aliens intelligent and skilled enough to
have gotten here would surely both sleep
and dream
sleep provides all manner of necessary
things to us and without good sleep we
are destined to be unhealthy and
unproductive and yet more than 30
percent of americans struggle with sleep
and temperature is one of the main
reasons it is well known that
individuals and couples who sleep
together often have different optimal
sleep temperatures eight sleep allows
fine-tuned temperature regulation for
both people having a cool room and a
warm bed is a luxury that ate sleep
makes easy to obtain so eight sleep
makes mattresses but their their big
deal is the pro no the pod pro cover by
eight sleep it's the most advanced
solution on the market for thermal
regulation you can add the cover to any
mattress and start sleeping as cool as
55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit not that i recommend
either of those extremes that's just
what you want and suitable for cooking
apparently yes you can have your eggs
right in bed with you the temperature of
the cover will adjust each side of the
bed based on your sleep stages
biometrics and bedroom temperature
reacting dynamically to create the
optimal sleeping environment eight sleep
users apparently fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by 40
and get more restful sleep overall i
said apparently because these are data
um we have not you know measured our own
experience sleeping but we do have one
of these and it's great and with 30 more
deep sleep on average according to the
data that eight sleep has collected that
restorative sleep will likely help with
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental clarity
and another feature which they actually
didn't write into the script that they
were hoping that we'd read is the alarm
feature
which can wake you with either
temperature change or slight vibration
at the chest level
and it's so much gentler than a standard
sonic alarm uh we are both surprised at
how much we appreciate this bed we were
a little we were we were not sure it's a
little bit it's a little high need to be
more technical yeah we we we tend to go
in the opposite direction we favor less
rather than more but um
uh but this this turns out to be um
pretty great yeah it solves real
difficult to solve problems
like
if one person likes it hot and the other
person likes it cool if the room is warm
then there's no way for the person who
likes it cool to get cool enough because
all you can do is reduce the amount of
cover and you're in a warm room but this
allows you to take heat out
yes indeed
so go to eight sleep that's
s l e e e-i-g-h-t-s-l-e-e-p
eight sleep dot com slash dark horse to
check out the pod pro cover and save 150
at checkout eight sleep ships to the u.s
canada and the uk at this point
all right our second sponsor this week
is vevo barefoot shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by and usually that someone
doesn't actually know feet or what they
can do they presumably have feet but
that doesn't mean they know them
vivo barefoot and contrast nose feet
these shoes are a revelation
we love them they're beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing they cause
no pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic in fact
i've just ordered another pair and one
for a younger son too
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot but modern
shoes that are overly cushioned and
strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a health crisis one in
which people move less than they might
in part because their shoes make their
feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by
sixty percent in a matter of months just
by walking around in them
the number of people wearing vivo
barefoots is growing it's an odd little
club easily recognizable
once people start wearing these shoes
they don't seem to stop so go to
vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash dark horse i'm going to
suggest to them the possible slogan viva
barefoot walk it on
nice i like that it's not bad yeah right
i thought it was going to take time to
hit you but no no no i saw it right away
that's great that was too dismissive
earlier i feel like you need to please
i've got credit in the bank
that's good
all right
um
our final sponsor today is public goods
public goods was one of our very first
sponsors last year and we are pleased
with them now as we were when you first
tried their products public goods can
simplify your life as a one-stop shop
for everyday essentials their
ingredients are carefully sourced high
quality and affordable public goods has
coffee and tea grains and oils like all
of an avocado they've got castile soap
and trash bags and laundry detergent
they have spices and extracts like
vanilla and almond
almond vinegars and pastas dishware
glassware
there's so much at public goods to make
a meal including the materials to serve
it on public goods products have a great
design too the aesthetic is simple and
clean and there are no garish colors
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are
largely free of harmful ingredients and
additives and the ingredients are
ethically sourced finally
their subscription service is efficient
and simple and easy to use public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place it really is an
everything store for dark horse
listeners we have the following offer
receive 15 off your first public goods
order with no minimum purchase they are
so confident that you will absolutely
love their products and come back again
and again that they are giving you
fifteen dollars to spend on your first
purchase
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse
use the code darkhorse at chat or use
the code dark words at checkout that is
public goods p u b l i c g
d dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15 off your first order
all right
you seem to have changed up our
background
well
you know
just i thought i would honor the uh the
person who um
did you bring over uh the their names
such good so we received this piece of
art in the uh in the mail and it's it's
wonderful it's wonderful somebody
clearly spent a great deal of time yeah
and uh anyway yeah so we thank you and
uh
yes okay where do you want to start ah
um i don't know we could we could start
with the the ivermectin together trial
all right
issue and i should say we are not going
to exhaustively explore this matter
because for one thing quite a number of
people have done extensive explorations
here and some of them are so excellent
that you really owe it to yourself
to look at them so i would include in
that chris martinson has done
an exploration
matthew 1 t crawford has done one
um phil harper has done one and i will
talk touch on one of the points that he
makes uh in a couple of minutes here and
alexandros marinus has also done
an excellent a couple of analyses as
well as a thread in which he compiles
some of the analyses that other people
have done
and uh ivm meta you can show me right
you can show my screen here if if you
like which is a a relatively
long-standing long-standing with regard
to covid
site
has
you know has an ongoing exhaustive
description of what the various studies
show don't show what their weaknesses
are etc and um zach if you just put my
screen back on for a moment here um this
with regard to um
specifically the together study uh they
just have a number you know it's an
ongoing list many of which are points
that have been made by for instance
alexandros and matthew and chris and
such
um but uh just just to just to look at a
couple of them there are many basic
inconsistencies and protocol violations
um there's no response to a data request
they've got different two different
death counts the trial was not blind
uh unequal randomization confounding my
time and then i skipped the second one
here which is delayed by six months and
i'm going to let you basically talk
about this for the most part the whole
thing but i did want to say that here on
ibm meta
they say the paper was delayed every six
months with no explanation so this is
this um this this big study um the
results were revealed back in august of
2021 and then i think it was the
fluoxamine arm which was published
within a couple weeks
and then nothing and so there are a lot
of people who upon hearing the results
which basically were uh ivermectin is
useless you know don't bother uh we were
you know we were right all along not
that that's what the authors here said
but that was the sort of the take in the
in the media
um
many everyone who cared about this
results immediately said well you know
i'm gonna need to look at the at the
analysis um there's not even a way to
look at the data because the data still
aren't being um produced but um the
thing wasn't published for six months
and so ivmetta says
one possible reason would be rejection
from a series of journals which would be
expected given the issues it's a
possibility we have no idea if that's
true
you know that was not my guess as to why
it would have been delayed but yeah but
it is it is remarkable that suddenly
this week everyone is talking about this
as if this is as if this is news
um and it was you know it was news in
august and now we can see how really
unnews it is because the study is so
flawed it's not even on news it's
anti-news and uh you know phil harper
addresses this very directly and so i
want to
highlight his analysis do you have uh
something to show yeah he's got well i
actually don't have something to show
but i would advise people to sign up for
his sub stack he has a seven day free
trial you can look at the whole thing
um but in any case
he um talks about you can just ch i've
just pulled it up and you've just pulled
it out yeah yeah
so this is yeah um
so yeah he he says the can't add
together trial i would say they can't
even keep it together trial so
what iv meta raises as the possibility
for why this is so delayed that it was
rejected from multiple places before the
new england journal of medicine finally
accepted it
the reason that that doesn't quite add
up and strikes me as more more generous
than uh
than it needs to be is that were
all of the errors here to have been
spotted by
reviewer after reviewer and
journals to have passed on this that
would have forced them to be corrected
in a sense some of them are so basic the
errors are just simple arithmetic errors
right that if these things were being
caught
then it's hard to imagine how it could
have landed in such a high profile
journal in such a crazy state i mean
it's really just riddled with errors
um so that does suggest
that like so much in this landscape of
early treatment covid public health
policy and all
that the distortions here are about
something it's that it's the immense
gravitational force of some object we
cannot see right is that object simply
pharma profits we don't know but what we
know is that nothing works in this
landscape like it's supposed to and one
of the things that doesn't work is not
only was this
delayed it's not really even delayed the
point is the
punch line was given to us and then the
basis for that punchline was delayed by
more than six months so this thing was a
weapon
in the hands of those who
argued that there was no utility to uh
to this particular early treatment this
was a weapon over that entire period
without our ability to discover how good
a weapon it or how accurate it was and
then upon its release the point is okay
suddenly there's all this fanfare and
the wall street journal is publishing on
the fact that um this study finally you
know remember you were told randomized
controlled trials are the gold standard
of science that's what you were told
right
well here is what you are now told is
the largest randomized controlled trial
that's been done on this topic
well technically but it wasn't done well
i mean this is this is exactly this is
the kind of explicit and intentional and
seems category error that we've been
talking about across the board right
like well uh vaccines have been
effective in reducing rates of
rates and of and deaths from rabies cool
therefore anything that we call a
vaccine for a particular uh disease uh
is something that you need uh wait you
know right so even if it were true uh
that randomized control trials were the
thing that you absolutely need to
demonstrate efficacy which it's which is
not true right um but that doesn't mean
that anything that calls itself a
randomized control trial is done well um
or you know is it is done well at all
and to your point about you know the
wall street journal you know
every mainstream outlet
is
very happy about this result that ought
to be giving us pause why are people so
pleased that early treatment with with a
drug that has a long safety record is
not effective against what we are being
told is the worst scourge to hit
humankind in a hundred years that seems
surprising um but then we even have like
this this headline just struck me as
particularly remarkable so show my
screen if you would again zach this is
from newsweek what joe rogan has said
defending ivermectin as drug is ruled
ineffective
ruled yeah now this is a headline author
and headlines are often crazy
and um you know presumably has nothing
to do with the person who wrote this and
you can get rid of that because it's now
of course of course here it's you know
it's showing trump right who has nothing
to do at all with ivermectin in fact
he's pro-vaccine right um
so um
what the headline writer reveals though
and no one who saw this at newsweek
before putting this up caught is that
they think this is about
it's like a court of law it's like a
standard of of
of proof like you would find in a court
of law ruled ruled ineffective that's
not how science works
science doesn't work
by uh by
democracy by vote that's that's not what
should be going on here and yet that is
clearly what we are seeing as this thing
finally gets published and suddenly
everyone who was so thrilled to be
talking about horse dewormer last summer
is back talking about all the same
things they've been talking about before
without actually
paying any attention to the fact that
the study itself is flawed you know i
don't even know how many at least 20
different ways yeah
and
presumably there are many out there who
didn't know what to think
right who probably did accept randomized
controlled trials are the gold standard
of science you know nobody having
thought through how many things were
never exposed to a randomized controlled
trial that we know
work how many things are incapable of
being exposed to a randomized controlled
trial that we do science in other ways
um
but lots of people probably accepted oh
well randomized controlled trial is
certainly the best kind of science and
so oh this is the largest randomized
controlled trial done on this topic well
what did it say about ivermectin it says
it doesn't work right the problem is
a couple things one
randomized and controlled right
randomly assigning people to two groups
one of which is a placebo control
group which controls for effects that
are not part of the treatment right
this among the errors here are errors
that suggest that this was neither
randomized nor placebo-controlled now
one of the
most the most curious errors in the
entire list
is that a huge fraction of the people in
the placebo group did not complete the
trial
right they bailed out of the placebo
group right much larger than the number
who left the treatment group
right which either
suggests that
given the way that dosaging was
happening it was it was relatively it
wasn't really blind it was pretty easy
to tell if you which group you were
that's one possibility so in this
particular case the study was done and
people who were sick with covid that's
how you got into the trial you were sick
with covid um
thought they were potentially going to
get treated with a drug that was reputed
to work right and in the place where the
trial was done lots of people were
talking about the utility of this drug
so if you were a person looking to get
treated you could join this trial and
maybe be treated for free and then you
discover you're in the control group by
one way or another and then maybe you
leave which would explain a massive
difference in the rate at which people
if you know lots of people didn't
complete but they were evenly
distributed between the two you could
say maybe there's something about how
hard it is for people to get to the
place where they get the drug or whoever
but it doesn't need it doesn't need
discussion or explanation if it's
roughly equal if it's roughly equal but
wildly unequal either suggest that those
people who were in the placebo group
knew they were in the placebo group and
weren't inclined to complete a trial
where they weren't getting treatment for
a disease they had that they considered
serious or it suggests that the effect
of the drug was significant enough that
they could detect that they weren't
getting better right so even in a
blinded thing if ivermectin worked you
could imagine that it would unblind
itself in this way but the so the point
is nothing adds up with respect to a
drug that doesn't work and is being
exposed to a randomized controlled trial
that results in a large fraction of the
people in the placebo group mysteriously
dropping out asymmetrically right that
just doesn't add up so here's the
question if randomized controlled trial
is the gold standard
this was not a randomized controlled
trial and yet according to the wall
street journal it's the largest
randomized controlled trial that's been
done on this topic so the point is
nothing in this
even superficially passes muster
and what's more
if you think about what was you know one
of the few good things about the way the
pandemic unfolded was that at the very
beginning of the pandemic science was
being done out in the open was peer
review happening well review by peers
was certainly happening it was happening
on this podcast and elsewhere as people
were looking at science that was
emerging that hadn't yet gone through
the the official process of peer review
it was amazing we talked about it it
felt like the wild west the pre-print
servers were just full they were just
you know
hundreds more papers weekly and it was
extraordinary it was the actual studies
and were the actual studies all good no
but you could look at them and you could
say well here's what's wrong with this
one here you know oh this one actually
looks pretty good because they accounted
for the thing that would trip up you
know another methodology
so actual review by peers happened in
this case early on the later we have
gotten the more this has been inverted
and i just want to point out how
perfectly the inversion worked here the
inversion worked so that what we got
here was not the ability to scrutinize
anything in fact we were denied the
ability to scrutinize anything for more
than six months what we got was a
conclusion that matched somebody's
desire right and then the point was well
what are the chances that that's what
the study actually says and that it does
so on the basis of sound science and
sound philosophy of science right many
of us thought the chances were low but
there was no ability to do exactly what
we're supposed to do which is go in
there and look and say well how good was
your methodology your methodology could
be good maybe you didn't follow it how
good was your methodology and did you
follow it and in this case
what we see is oh it's garbage long
after the six-month period in which
people
portrayed this trial as definitive and
long after the wall street journal and
others touted this as well the evidence
is finally in right now what are the
chances that all of the people who got
suckered a few days ago
and saw the wall street journal touting
this are going to find phil harper or
alexandros morenos or chris martinson or
any of these people right the point is
this is a way to sell a conclusion as
science-based when the science itself is
not robust
that's that's exactly right
um i was struck
uh
by actually one of the fines that
alexandros made
with regard to the the dosing uh right
so the protocol says uh that the dosing
given in the ivermectin arm was is it
400 micrograms per kilogram of body
weight for three days
but
he went digging into the supplement
protocol supplement you know again not
the entire data set with the protocol
supplement and the
detail that he finds there is that
actually that's not true
that that's only true up to body weights
of 90 kilograms and then it sort of it
just it tops out and there's no
justification for that either given or
anywhere else in the ivermectin
literature right and what that means is
that for people who are frankly pretty
much you know most people above 90
kilograms are probably overweight not
all some people are tall
um but um
but in general
the
greater chances you have of being
overweight the greater chances you have
of having been underdosed uh in this
trial with regard to ivermectin and
there's nothing except hidden in the
supplement
by someone who was really trying to
figure out what happened
to indicate that at all and so you know
it it
this is just one example and there are
lots of these examples but there's just
so many ways that the study did not do
what it claimed to do and then you have
places like newsweek saying well
basically
the jury came back yep and it's like
that's not what we're doing here oh wait
actually apparently it is because the
jury came back means newsweek in the
wall street journal in the new york
times and huffpo and i'm just making
places up because i assume everyone has
written their ridiculous piece accepted
the conclusion from the authors or from
you know new england general americans
press
medicine's press release and um hasn't
taken the time and probably doesn't have
the the chops of the wherewithal to
actually go in and check or even to look
at you know any of these analyses that
have been done by the people you've
mentioned i would also point out that
this is not just a matter of lay people
not having the chops to go in right
it shouldn't be the case but scientists
all too frequently look at the title and
maybe the abstract of something and
assume that the work is done well and it
is amazing how frequently one goes into
a paper and one sees that actually even
the abstract isn't justified by the the
method section for example very often um
yeah it's really common
um and you know methods methods are
tough if you're outside of your
particular field
and they're they're just they're hard to
read
but
they are necessary if you are actually
going to decide that what it is that the
authors have claimed
uh is true
i would also point out that the one
thing i will say um you know by way of
steel manning this trial which i really
don't feel like deserves it because the
the number of things that everyone else
is still manning it for us yeah but even
so
just the number of things that are wrong
in the same direction does not suggest
good faith how that happened i don't
know but um it's it's conspicuous and so
you know my feeling is steel manning
only makes sense when the thing on the
other side is a different perspective
and you want to give it it's due but it
doesn't really have a do if it's if it's
cheating
um but
uh what was i going to say i was going
to say um
oh yeah
it is very let us admit that or just
acknowledge that
a
a study like this
is hugely complex right yes and it's not
only complex at the level of well what
would the study have to do and what
things would have to be compared in
order to um to accomplish the goal and
you know lots of things that viewers of
this podcast will be well familiar with
like uh you know you can sabotage a
trial or you can screw it up by treating
too late right things like that or you
could in the case of ivermectin you
could give it um without food so that it
wouldn't uh cross the gut as they did as
they did right but the point is there's
lots of complexity or they recommended
that it be taken on an empty stomach
right what are the chances that you
would do a study of this complexity
without making some errors i'd say
they're effectively zero yeah there will
be some errors now it's been a lot of
months since the result came out so you
know there i think one of the things was
like there i don't remember even what
the numbers were but it's like was it
228 or 288 i don't even remember where
in there but well
you know typos happen
mistakes happen in the relating of
results if they happened in the original
data that's a big problem but also
there's been a lot of time for a lot of
people on a study this big with this
many authors to really go through and
check and check and check yeah and
there's also a right way to deal with it
either your study is uh so compromised
by the errors that you don't publish it
because it's not evidence or it's
compromised in a way that let's say you
lose some fraction of the individuals
who were in the study because they
discovered they were in the placebo
group for example and so it's that part
of the study is no longer placebo
controlled but some other group wasn't
aware right so then the point is then
you scale back what study you publish so
that the study you publish is actually
evidence of something right and the
point is okay they made errors some of
the errors may just be the normal fact
of a complex study but the point is
there's a right honorable way to deal
with the errors that you make in a study
such as that and that didn't happen here
it didn't happen at the editor level it
didn't happen at the level of the peer
reviewers it didn't happen at the level
of how this evidence emerged into public
you know it's one thing to see a
preprint where you get to see the
conclusion of the study and you get to
see how the study was done and you can
compare them it's another thing to get
to see the conclusion and not be able to
see how the study was done there's no
preprint and then then the point is this
is pr right this was effectively
a psyop as so much in this neighborhood
has been and so anyway final thing i
want to say is
science is supposed to work right and i
don't mean science the philosophy of
science scientific method but science
the practice of science in modernity is
supposed to work on the basis that we
want things explored we society want
things explored we provide incentives
that come to those in a position to do
the work in the form of
jobs in the form of promotions in the
form of grants in the form of prizes
right all of these things are given for
high quality work that elucidates stuff
in a way that is good and those
incentives draw people to discover
things right
but if those incentives are not not
targeted at hey discover what the truth
of ivermectin is but they're targeted at
here's a story that we need to be
supported by science looking stuff they
can do that too if you give the prizes
and the jobs and the promotions and the
grants to people who come up with a
story that some very powerful entity
wants told then that's what science will
do and in this particular case we do
know
that you know the apparatus surrounding
anthony fauci is the behemoth of grant
awarding right that thing
is in a position to control a huge
fraction of the money which serves the
purpose of the incentive in the system
so what that has to do with how this
trial came about we don't know but the
fact that you would get a trial
that
uh claims to be essentially definitive
by claiming the mantle of what they have
called the gold standard which i will
argue is actually about something else
but we've been told randomized
controlled trial is the gold standard
right this trial
claims to be the largest randomized
controlled trial of this particular
treatment and it comes to a conclusion
that is well treatment doesn't work
right that is how you tell a story and
the fact that it wasn't a randomized
controlled trial
right uh that it pretends to be one but
isn't one is part and parcel of what's
going on here so my my claim is going to
be
that this idea that randomized
controlled trial is the gold standard
is actually a
trope of sorts there is a way in which
it can be true if a randomized control
trial is done well
right if if the philosophy of science
underneath it is sound if the
methodology is good and if the
methodology is followed well then it is
going to be the best way to elucidate
especially a subtle pattern right
however
i don't think that's why it is being
shoved at us as the gold standard it's
being shoved at us because it is the
most gameable right because just as a
good methodology
is amplified by randomized controlled
trial a bad methodology is too and
well it's gameable but i would say
another point in its favor in scare
quotes is that it can't be done by
individuals without uh large backing oh
right so you know you you can't come in
and you know and try to understand the
study in retrospect the way that uh the
way that alexandra's and matthew and
phil and chris and you know and
are and that we have in a lot of other
places and you know that's that is as it
should be but in order to and and you
know we we have ourselves done not in
this not in this sphere um but a lot of
uh very low-tech low-cost science and in
fact i used to encourage this um not
just for myself for my students like you
you don't want something that's going to
require a lot of money because then then
you're not nimble then you can you know
then you can't move at the point that
your funders say actually i don't like
what you're doing anymore right and
that's not to say that there aren't
questions that deserve to be asked and
that are important for humanity that
they'd be asked and answered that
require a lot of money there are but
there are also a lot there's too many
incentives to push money towards being
more expensive than it needs to be i say
money that pushes science towards being
more expensive than it needs to be
because
that renders those people doing the
science incapable of getting out so rcts
randomized control trials we can't do
those right individuals can't do those
right individuals can't do that you're
right that's another from the point of
view of something that wishes to control
the narrative that is a major feature
right that they somebody can't easily
bootstrap one so they're highly gameable
methodologically
uh and individuals can't uh can't do
them because they're too expensive i
think these are both driving driving
forces here i guess the last thing i
would say is there is a conspicuous
oddness to the together trial which i
haven't heard discussed in this last
phase which is that it
oddly
given
what it did here with ivermectin
concluded that fluvoxamine was highly
effective
right
now my point would be and that result
was then published within a couple of
weeks back in august yeah immediately
um
so here's the question that did not as
far as i'm aware radically changed the
standard of care so that people who had
kovit were getting fluvoxanine
why didn't it if the idea is well we'd
give him ivermectin if a randomized
controlled trial said it worked
okay it did with fluvoxamine what
happened to that
right so anyway i don't i'd be
interested to hear what the answer is on
that front but i think the point is
all of this looks like um you know the
little people the riff raff and by the
riffraff i mean us
right need to be placated or dismissed
in some way and there's going to be
enough science looking stuff to make
that happen
and um
the most annoying thing is that when we
try to hold them to any standard
whatsoever it's obvious that they're not
adhering to one right are there a whole
lot of people wearing scientist hats
science-ish hats yeah exactly um boy you
said a lot of things that
prompted me to want to go immediately to
all the different places i want to go
and probably won't get to all of it but
let me just let me jump before um going
into this uh
the need for evidence-based medicine
piece that was published a week and a
half ago or so
um
without the introduction that i will
later give it um i had
uh the honor of reading and gosh
is it matthias or matthias i'm not sure
uh matthias desmond
i i had the honor of reading matthias
desmond's uh book
uh the origins of totalitarianism in its
english translation uh published by
chelsea green publishing
and um this week
and it's going to be out
again maybe june 1st i'm not sure like
spanish spanish edition of our book and
and the english edition of
desmond's book are both out in june june
comes at you past june
probably will be coming out as fast yes
um excuse me and uh in advance of that
you brett are going to do a podcast with
him and um i expect that's going to be a
terrific conversation and i guess this
book is just terrific and you know it
pushed me and there's some stuff in here
that i don't agree with um but i'm i'm
trying to frame it you know he's a
i think he's a background in psychology
but he does history um and history of
science and science and he just does a
lot of really terrific things so i want
to read a few excerpts but something you
just said now probably 10 minutes ago
prompted me to want to read this excerpt
first this is um
i don't remember what chapter it's from
the use of numbers in this crisis so
here he's talking about coven okay
pandemic the last two years
the use of numbers in this crisis makes
us barely realize that what we do
respond to are not so much the facts but
the stories constructed around facts
those stories are spun by healthcare
workers who genuinely do their best to
help by people who don't want to see
their families suffer by politicians who
want to make the right decisions by
academics who want to provide
information as objectively as possible
however
they are also constructed by politicians
who are under the pressure of public
opinion and feel compelled to act
decisively by leaders who have lost
control into their opportunity to take
back the reins by experts who have to
hide their ignorance by academics who
see a chance to assert themselves by
man's inherent propensity for hysteria
and drama by pharmaceutical companies
that smell dollar bills by media that
thrive on sensational stories by
ideologies that see in a technocratic
totalitarian system the only solution to
the seemingly insoluble problems of our
time
so this is
this is this is this is brilliant and
there's so much in his book in which
he's basically
railing and that sounds like he's
unhinged which he really really is not
again this is desmet um in his book the
origins of totalitarianism which is
going to be published in english in a
couple of months by chelsea green
in which he takes on uh the reductionist
strictly materialist in his framing uh
and this is where i kind of i glitch a
little bit um but the very reductionist
um view of science that then gets handed
down to people as if all they have to do
is trust the people who say they're
doing the science and then they too are
living in a science state of of mind and
they too can hope for sort of a utopian
infinite life future in which there are
no problems right
and you know what what he reveals here
in part is
not just are the numbers not our saviors
but we're not even actually responding
to the numbers the numbers on their own
don't don't usually compel people they
compel some of us right the numbers
numbers and
well but not manipulative manipulatively
created graphs and tables will actually
compel those of us who are who are
driven to find meaning in numbers but
that's not most people and even those of
us
for whom that is true the vast majority
of us still find meaning in story easier
and it's easier to remember an emotional
level at a visceral level and so what
has happened to
us to all of us regardless of where we
fall in terms of what we believe and
what we don't believe what we think is
going on these last two years is we have
we have been handed a series of stories
and very often we don't even know that
because we think we're saying oh but you
know newest studies says ivermectin
doesn't work so it doesn't work
what are you a horse
yeah that right um
yeah i i wonder sometimes if people
don't need to spend a little bit of time
just
you can tell a lot about the story
you're being handed
by figuring out what the alternatives
that could fit in the same moment in
history would be right like
what what do people think
would have happened if
pharma had discovered that there was a
vast new market for novel patentable
profitable products
and it was unnecessary because a drug
that had gone out of patent was too
effective
what do they think pharma would have
said and done do they think pharma would
have said we are so lucky that one of
our past successes that can now be
produced by anybody because it's out of
patent
is capable of controlling this pandemic
and
you know it would have been nice from
our perspective if this had been a
business win
but um
but it turns out that humanity is
luckier than that and we are
we are grateful
do does anybody think anyone in business
ever sounds like that right
right um that said
i think this is a good moment to
actually to read another so wait i want
to take back one thing i said i think a
few people in business do sound like
that but the idea that's that an entire
industry would have reacted that way i
think is preposterous anyway go ahead um
so let me actually just uh kind of
introduce the book so matthias desmet as
many people listening uh will know will
recognize his name uh is uh
has publicized the idea of mass
formation also known as mass formation
psychosis uh the english you can show my
uh my screen here zach for a minute the
english version of his book the english
translation translation of his book is
being published by chelsea green
which is just an extraordinary
publishing company it's one that i had
already been familiar with but you go
through and you find um you know books
um about orchards and farming and covet
19 and pipelines and um you know cobb
houses and all sorts of things it's just
it's just um so lovely and i'm not gonna
do that now thanks chelsea green um but
okay i can i can take my screen back
here um oh and i mean i actually first
came to be i think fully aware of
chelsea green at the point that we were
reading uh derek jensen's books back uh
boy middle mid-aughts probably uh before
we knew him as we are as we are lucky to
to know him now
uh so you know he is a radical
environmentalist and extraordinary
educator as well so this book
um
in this book matthias desmet lays out uh
just a remarkable history and i'm not i
i could have written up an entire uh
description of what it is that he's
doing here but i think uh we'll we'll
just do some excerpts here and then
you'll have a conversation with him in
in several weeks and then i will
encourage everyone to read the book and
i'll put the link to the pre-order in
the show notes as well
um but he you know he talks about hannah
arendt
in the 40s i think i've forgotten now
talking about of course the origins of
totalitarianism and talking about mass
formation and also a french philosopher
named
in 1895 i believe talking about this
phenomenon so this is not this is
neither new with desmet nor new right
now nor is you know robert malone who
has helped you know publicize uh
desmet's work responsible for causing a
bunch of people to believe in something
that he just pulled out of thin air
you know this this not that old ideas
are inherently good or new ideas are
inherently bad but this is a concept
this idea of mass formation has been
banded about by very smart people who
have seen a lot of truth that other
people have not seen for well over 100
years at this point
yeah i would just say people should
check out um
chris martinson's chat with him they
have a they have a podcast it does yes
oh i did not know that that's uh that's
terrific but it is
um
okay so
chapter seven the leaders of the masses
um
this is
two pages
the chapter's longer than that the
excerpt i'm going to read is the
beginning of chapter seven which is two
pages
in the previous chapter i described the
again this is from desmet's
the origins of totalitarianism in the
previous chapter i described the
phenomenon of mass formation the
psychological basis of totalitarianism
as a form of hypnosis
however there is an important difference
between mass formation and classical
hypnosis in classical hypnosis only the
field of consciousness of the hypnotized
person is narrowed the person who
conveys the hypnotizing story the
hypnotist is awake
in mass formation to the contrary the
person who conveys the story is usually
in the grip of the story as well
in fact this person's field of attention
is usually even more narrow than that of
the masses
the reason is clear the leader usually
fanatically believes in the ideological
basis of the narrative not in the
narrative itself that controls the
masses so this is i'm just stepping
aside from the quote for a moment this
is a really critical distinction he's
not saying that the leader who is
effectively
hypnotizing masses in mass formation
believes the narrative but he believes
that the reason he's doing it is so
honorable because he believes in an
ideology that it's for their it's it's
for everyone's good it's for the best
it's what needs to happen in order to
attain the goal uh that he or she
fervently believes it's a noble psyop
is a noble psyop
back to back to desmond's words with
respect to the leaders with respect to
the leaders mass formation gives rise to
two opposing attitudes either one trusts
the leaders blindly and disappears into
the mass or one completely disrupts them
distrusts them and sees them as people
who knowingly carry out an evil plan i.e
conspirators in a certain sense both
extreme perspectives are based on a
similar misunderstanding they
fallaciously endowed the leaders with a
virtually absolute knowledge and power
the first group does so in a positive
sense the second group in a negative
sense other misconceptions are that the
leaders are primarily driven by money
you follow the money and cui bono or
sadistic pleasure i either have a
psychopathic or perverted personality
such statements are not really confirmed
by historical research either to give
one example the head of the nazi party
had a reluctant attitude toward illicit
profits and personalities with
tendencies towards perversion and
psychopathy were system systematically
excluded from recruitment
as opposed to the classical criminal who
finds an intrinsic pleasure in violating
social rules in this case totalitarian
criminality lies more in the uncritical
and mindless adherence to a system of
totalitarian social rules even when the
system becomes radically inhumane and
transcends each and every ethical
boundary
hence hannah arent's famous expression
that totalitarianism was a true
demonstration of the banality of evil
totalitarianism is not about monstrous
people it is about normal people who
stick to a morbid dehumanizing way of
thinking or logic
in the initial phase of the
totalization project process such a
logic first takes hold of the population
the masses or at least a large part of
the population become imbued with
certain ideological convictions that to
them are no longer distinguishable from
reality the emerging mass movements of
pan-slavism and pan-germanism in russia
and germany in the early 20th century
are good examples germans typically
became convinced that as a race they
were superior to others and that
stigmatization and oppression of amongst
others poles and jews could be justified
by quote the facts
we see something similar happening
during the coronavirus crisis where a
certain segment of the population is
becoming convinced that the facts
justify the social discrimination of
people who refuse to be vaccinated the
numbers show that they are spreading the
virus don't they
these dynamics slowly give rise to the
emergence of totalitarian parties and
totalitarian leaders who gradually
institutionalize this logic and impose
it on society and this typically happens
in a fanatical blind and merciless way
hitler believed that his strength came
from his ability for quote ice-cold
reasoning and stalin believed that the
secret of a success lay in his quote
merciless dialectics
races that were unfit for life and dying
classes were under the justification of
this logic expelled from society with
surgical precision
for this reason what characterizes the
leaders of the masses is not greed or
sadism but their morbid ideological
drive
reality must and will be adjusted to the
ideological fiction
this is
critical i think in part because one of
the questions we often get asked
is does this require conspiracy
does what we are seeing around us
require conspiracy and one of the things
that we get accused of of course is
being conspiracy theorists and of course
that word is just weaponized and that
phrase is just weaponized and
meaningless at this point
and from
what from its origin what does that mean
um
the phrase conspiracy theory uh emerges
and this is debated by various people
but it emerges in a document in which i
believe it is the cia argues
in favor of using this to
effectively stigmatize people who were
not satisfied with the warrant
commission's explanation of what
happened to john f kennedy
and so the idea that this was a way to
get rid of an entire kind of inquiry
is uh
from the outset yeah
but
you know
no one
intelligent
and i don't mean educated i mean
intelligent
um of which there is some overlap um not
total in either direction
should imagine that conspiracies don't
exist in the world they certainly do if
your bias is to see conspiracy
everywhere every time anything happens
uh you are no doubt seeing it too many
places and if you're biases to say that
it never happens anywhere then your
biases is in the opposite direction and
is also an error
but what desmond lays out here following
again from a rent and this philosopher
lebanon with whom i was not previously
familiar
is that uh it's
in order for the leaders of something
that becomes mass formation to take
place what you need is ideological
certainty
and a belief that they're doing the
right thing they do not need to be
greedy they do not need to be
conspirators they do not to be sadists
they do not you know they they actually
don't need to be driven by any of the
other things many of which presumably
many of them are also driven by
but it's not necessary
so um
there's obviously a lot that
one could extrapolate
from here too and one thing that
uh i think is important is the way in
which something that was suffused
through all of the functional apparatus
of western civilization everything
from uh you know from
the democratic party to
the major newspapers
um
to the regulatory apparatus to twitter
right
they are all suffused with something in
advance of the totalitarian impulse
right and so uh
i and others have talked about william
binney describing the turnkey
totalitarian state
the idea that totalitarianism is built
around you but it's not turned on at
first and so it's it's a very much more
frightening thing because you don't see
it it doesn't look like totalitarianism
until somebody flicks the switch on it
um but there's a way in which this
organically happens too right if the
idea is that everybody you know
everybody through all of the control
architecture of western civilization
went through college somewhere right and
as they went through college somewhere
they were fed something that was um
very simple
about right and wrong and which side
they were on and who the bad people were
and at the point it was handed to them
it was just sort of an impassing kind of
observation that western civilization is
fundamentally racist for example right
right you can accept that and if
nobody's saying what you're supposed to
do about it then the point is oh well i
guess i believe that
and then the point is at the point they
come knocking and they say well you
remember how you agreed that western
civilization was racist here's what that
requires you to do right your obligation
so as to not be complicit
is now x y and z you have to go after
all of the people who don't agree right
for example it's it's a it's a version
of give them an inch they take a mile
once once you've agreed to one of the
premises that um
that
you know may or may not be true
if if you can be held to that by your
own moral standards then you can
actually have your morality twisted out
from under you right you have to have
some sort of an active process so that
a you're either the kind of skeptical
person who when they hear western
civilization as racist
their question is what do you mean by
that exactly right right um
or you've got to be the kind of person
who when they come knocking and they say
remember how you agreed that western
civilization was racist well now here's
what you're required to do about it the
answer is uh in what way does this
follow and can we go back to your
original assertion because i was always
a bit in doubt about what you meant
do you mean there has been racism
throughout that there have been lots of
barriers placed in people's way i agree
do i agree that that's the fundamental
nature of what western civilization is
about but that's it's you know cinquano
no i don't agree right and you know it's
very hard to be either one of those
right it's a lot of energy to be
resisting when it seems like nothing's
at stake well um
so i mean i could i could read excerpts
all day and i'll only do a couple of of
more but one of the things i'm reminded
of from what could have been a
three-page expert but i but i won't do
it is
you know he says
desmet argues
as
as we have as many others have there's
basically sort of three groups um of of
people and um you've i remember you
describing this before evergreen blew up
in fact
four groups okay go for it so describe
describe those groups and then i'll fit
that this is what i put on the board two
days before uh 50 students i'd never met
showed up at my classroom accusing me of
racism
that there are four groups there were a
small number of people who will
lead who will instigate a witch hunt
there's a large number of people who
will go along with them there's an even
larger group of people who will say
nothing
and then there's a tiny group of people
who will stand up and say witches don't
exist and those are your witches
excellent excellent um so
uh he just hasn't named the leaders as
one of the groups here that's all um
we've identified three groups that form
a mass arises the masters the masses
themselves who truly go along with the
story and are hypnotized he estimates
about 30
a group that is not hypnotized but
chooses to not go against the grain
usually about 40 to 60 he estimates this
again desmet and a group that is not
hypnotized and actively resists the
masses ranging from 10 to 30
okay that's
us right
probably the the people who are
listening um hopefully there are some in
that middle group i think there's very
few in the first group who are listening
here although i would hope so he then
proceeds and i i won't read the whole
thing here to describe what it is that
if you are in that third group the group
that is not hypnotized and is actively
resisting the mass is what what you
should be doing and why what the value
is in it but the the
key of it the central nugget is
the first and foremost guideline for
members of this third group is that they
should let their voices be heard and in
as sincere a way as possible so as not
to let the resonance of the dominant
hypnotic voice become absolute
do it whatever way you can
do it in the grocery store do it on
screens do it with your family you know
just do not
simply be quiet and assume that this
will pass
because that will be how they win
that will be how the dominant hypnotic
mass voice becomes the only voice that
anyone can hear and so then that first
group grows in size and it's pulling
from the second group but the second
group may be growing in size two maybe
pulling even from those who are
currently not hypnotized
um
in his book uh how how extensively does
he go into a connection with renee
gerrard does he i don't think uh at all
it's not there interesting i don't i
it's not i the document i have isn't
searchable so i can't i don't think so
so it seems to me that there's like a
whole little cluster of
uh
people who have studied the same but
apologies i may be misremembering
aspects of the same phenomenon
uh
gerard desmond orent
stanley milgram
ash solomon ash of course yep uh
yeah okay no that's not that's not true
i can search it and gerard isn't in here
not in there ashes interesting um but
anyway it's
the number of places where
you have some
version of
you know the people are hypnotized by
something what is it right is it the the
uh the lab coat of the experimenter in
stanley milgram's
case that causes people to reflexively
go into a subordinate phase in which
they'll shock somebody to death because
a scientist told them to is it anonymous
peers in the case of ash right is it a
need to
scapegoat in order to find cohesion in
society in gerard's case sorry anonymous
stranger appears yeah anonymous but yeah
um
anyway all of these things are clearly
explorations of a related set of
phenomena at the very least absolutely
uh how important is it that we figure
this out because we're just going to
keep living it again and again it is
so critical so i am going to
uh read one more short excerpt from
from
desmet and then
two sentences but um
here we go
again all i have is the page number so
remember what chapter this is from
the catalyst for mass formation is a
suggestion in the public sphere
if under the aforementioned
circumstances a suggestive story is
spread through the mass media that
indicates an object of anxiety for
example the aristocracy under stalinism
the jews under nazism the virus and
later the anti-vaxxers during the
coronavirus crisis
at the same time offers a strategy to
deal with that object of anxiety there
is a real chance that all the
free-flowing anxiety will attach itself
to that object and there will be broad
social support for the implementation of
the strategy to control that object of
anxiety
this process yields a psychological gain
firstly the anxiety that previously
roamed through society is a tenebrus
tenebrous fog is now linked to a
specific cause and can be mentally
controlled via the strategy put forward
in the story
secondly through a common struggle with
the enemy the disintegrating society
regains its coherence energy and
rudimentary meaning
for this reason the fight against the
object of anxiety then becomes a mission
laden with pathos and group heroism for
example the belgian government's team of
11 million going to war against the
coronavirus
thirdly in this fight all latent brewing
frustration and aggression is taken out
especially on the group that refuses to
go along with the story and the mass
formation
this brings on enormous release and
satisfaction to the masses which they
will not let go of easily
wow yeah so much of that is
resonant from now a couple of chapters
of our recent life right it just it's
unmistakable right that
you you're
the experience is certainly one of
facing
a hypnotized group it's like
sleepwalkers and yeah and and
simultaneously
i'm i'm the enemy right what what what
happened and so and and many many in our
audience will have experienced this um
in at least some ways in these last two
years at this point you know
whether or not
um you know wherever they think the
virus came from whatever they think of
the vaccines whatever they think of
early treatment if you're spending any
time listening to us you probably don't
simply accept everything that comes out
of
the cdc's and nih's
mouthpiece's mouths right and so you
probably occasionally say something that
causes people to go what now
and
it's like it's there's a laser focus on
on the person who dissents
on the person who dissents as
uh a place to focus the anxiety like i
now see it i know see that you're the
enemy and now that i have an enemy um i
know what i can do all i have to do is
get rid of the enemy right and it's done
it's amazing how
something has caused
um
the
paradoxical and ironic idea of
scientific consensus sudden scientific
consensus to be the good thing right
gravitating to the sudden consensus puts
you on the side of good and who are the
enemy the enemy are people who are
resisting sudden scientific consensus
and the answer is
sorry scientific consensus is either
over something trivial that's very
easily demonstrated and therefore it
only takes once you know if you drop a
hammer and a feather on the moon they
fall at the same rate right
um
or
or or some things over in physics space
where it only takes once um like um
einstein's observation of the
gravitational
gravitational lensing uh or you know
even so that's not trivial even the
multi-slit experiment yeah you can see
it in a single instance right right i
agree
with that um but in terms of complex
phenomena right right expect i mean the
thing is the farther you get towards
complexity the more you're dealing with
multiple inputs the more you're dealing
with noise the harder it is to even
describe the pattern in question right
so the idea of sudden consensus around
something like a new virus and what
works to treat it and
how it's going to react to the
introduction of that treatment and all
of that this is no place for it's it's
no place where sudden consensus is even
conceivable
so the idea that those who are the enemy
are those who are resistant to the
sudden consensus it's like well i think
you just
you know painted a target on every
single real scientist
right no and that's um
those who are walking around trying to
experience having a life uh are
presumably not trying to paint target on
every every actual scientist but that is
the effect and so just at the very at
the end of that section that i just read
a couple paragraphs from he writes the
masses believe in the story not because
it's accurate but because it creates a
new social bond
and i think this is a piece that is
often missing from an analysis that
relies entirely on um you know but why
do they believe that like you know it's
not true
and uh especially after two years of the
kinds of
um behavioral modifications and and
experiences that we've all had or rather
failed to have via lockdowns and remote
schooling and zoom meetings and all of
this
the you know the desire for people to
have an actual social bond is even
stronger than it was before which is
hard to imagine because we are above all
social creatures but uh the idea that
the story you know oh i can offer you a
social bond and it happens to come with
a story that uh just don't pay too much
attention to the man behind the curtain
cool i'm not going to pay too much
attention to the man behind the curtain
because what i really like is now
feeling like the in-group and like we're
on the right path again and i'm moving
towards the future and towards safety
and hey look at all my new friends
and that's just
it feels great to people and that you
know that's part of why they tune in to
you know the mainstream media going ra
ra look at us aren't we aren't we all on
the right side of history
and
that works as a sales pitch regardless
of whether or not you're actually on the
right side of history
yes the desire to be in that group is so
powerful that the what what is the group
rallying around is secondary and so lots
of people who you know
feel like
i mean i remember in a prior era right
the
um
the democrats
felt superior for being the darwinists
right they were never very good at it
right but they were superior in their
own minds for being the ones who had
embraced this very important
insight
and it is
as you know you and i both know a
vitally important insight but the point
is most of the people who were feeling
great about being on darwin's team
didn't really understand what the
insight was or why it was so important
they just kind of
um
[Music]
had the sense that it was you know that
the enlightened people were ahead in
this regard that darwin's a little hard
to swallow but they were there early
i've actually got so zach just put up my
screen quickly i've got a piece in
huffpo this half post tough po
this week um
no actually it's from march 15th but i
just saw it this week um herschel
walker's skeptical of evolution why are
there still apes think about it
so you know this is a former nfl player
who's now running for senate who doesn't
get evolution and he's a conservative
and so the liberals are really excited
to point out that he doesn't understand
evolution but you read this article and
i'm not going to do it i'm not going to
recommend that you do but i'll post in
the show notes and you see the person
writing the article doesn't get it
either right you know they they sort of
skirt around it but it's clear they
don't really know why
what he said is false they just have
been assured that it's false right and
so you know this this struck me you know
i didn't know you were going to say what
you just said but this struck me exactly
it's like well sure aren't don't we feel
virtuous for understanding this thing
except here too
like i can explain i could explain to
hershel walker or the or the author of
this article why what he said why he is
what his misunderstanding is and what it
actually means that there are both apes
and humans still here today but neither
of the people and most of the people on
both sides of this argument couldn't do
it and so it's entirely it's back to
that newsweek thing it's like it's about
it's about judgment as opposed to
reality and science right which leads to
one of my least favorite moves in
analytical space right which is when
somebody is caught in that bind right
where they know herschel walker
is not
onto something by having discovered that
they still exist right they don't know
what's wrong with what he said and so
the point is oh the last thing i want to
do is say he's wrong and then have
somebody say oh really why so what they
do is they
amplify how obvious it is that he's
wrong and how obvious it is why he's
wrong so that they basically bluff and
they say
anybody who doesn't know why that's
wrong is a fool so then the point is if
you ask the question you're
stepping into the role of fool aren't
you so you wouldn't want to do that so
you're not going to ask me the question
are you and it's created in order not to
be asked i mean just as you said like
okay i don't want to have to pronounce
anything here because the fact is i
don't understand this
so i'm going to be really loud and
bombastic about making fun of the people
who think the other thing it's exactly
what we're seeing with regard to the the
together trial being published you know
all you know both both individuals and
and mainstream media pronouncing loudly
what a you know what a fool joe rogan is
and you know and we are and all of this
like
none of you actually have
bothered to try to understand the
science right no they're revealing how
little they know about um how the
thought process even works right what
the underlying philosophy of science
that makes the engine function is right
they don't know and they're revealing it
to us they're not revealing it to other
people who don't know
um
and so anyway it's maddening
um but but nonetheless it is effective
yeah
uh so apologies for the noise guys it's
a beautiful spring day and we have the
windows open today and and a truck
yes
and uh that was the
postman who looks
like a famous celebrity whose name is
slipping my mind i think it's justin
wilson yeah oh
yeah it's not owen well somebody looks
like it
he was gone before i looked anyway now i
think we've had this conversation before
i will yes
okay um
a couple more things uh oh wow it's
after six okay a couple more things
it's after six somewhere it's after six
right here okay um
this is a you can show my screen this is
published actually same same moment that
herschel walker tough post kerfuffle
happened um march 16 2022 in the british
medical journal that's bmj stands for
british medical journal yeah um an op-ed
by two researchers called the illusion
of evidence-based medicine
uh sub-type subheading being
evidence-based medicine has been
corrupted by corporate interests failed
regulation and commercialization of
academia argue these authors and let me
just read
this paragraph
which for some reason i've only
highlighted all but the last line the
philosophy of critical rationalism
advanced by the philosopher karl popper
famously advocated for the integrity of
science and its role in an open
democratic society a science of real
integrity would be one in which
practitioners are careful not to cling
to cherished hypotheses and take
seriously the outcome of the most
stringent experiments this ideal is
however threatened by corporations in
which financial interests trump the
common good this is not
antithetical to what desmond is arguing
it sounds like it might be but it's not
he does not argue that there aren't
possible financial interests that are
doing bad things in the world
he's just saying you don't need that in
order to see mass formation forming back
to the op-ed
medicine is largely dominated by a small
number of very large pharmaceutical
companies that compete for market share
but are effectively united in their
efforts to expanding that market the
short-term stimulus to biomedical
research because of privatization has
been celebrated by free market champions
but the unintended long-term
consequences for medicine have been
severe
scientific progress is thwarted by the
ownership of data and knowledge because
industry suppresses negative trial
results fails to report adverse events
and does not share raw data with the
academic research community
patients die because of the adverse
impact of commercial interests on the
research agenda universities and
regulators
so that came out two weeks before the
together trial was finally published
ivermectin are the together trial was
finally published but it's uh it's
rather in keeping
so uh it it actually is an excellent
place to make a particular point great
um the
we tend to think of
actually i've been fighting this uh
battle a little bit since uh since back
in game b days when we say something
like capture right
capture which is now a common phrase
since covet is a common phrase in most
people's minds
capture is a reference to an earlier
phrase regulatory capture and regulatory
capture was a much narrower phenomenon
than what we mean when we say capture
right capture is a very general
phenomenon it involves the capture of
university professors it involves the
capture of
newspapers it involves the capture of
all the things that
sway
policy ultimately
and the regulators are one that's one
core thing that you have to capture in
order to get ahead through this sort of
mechanism but anyway the point is
the proper instantiation for the concept
is not the specific one because if you
say
oh what's going on is the result of
regulatory capture then people only see
the regulators and they say it's not a
big enough that that couldn't be doing
this and the point is no
zoom out right this is ex this is
extended capture as i think i've called
it before
and
unless you instantiate capture as
something in which regulators are
included but it is not limited to them
you won't understand it's its power and
so likewise the concept of corruption
right
corruption is corruption about uh
bribery and financial incentives it
certainly includes that but it can
include lots of stuff it can include
prestige right there are lots of people
who'll be
will be persuaded by prestige um uh as
you will remember i
uh used to argue about what what golf
junkets were doing why lobbyists were
taking their clients on
their clients is the wrong term but
their uh targets
on targets golf junkets yeah and uh
there was one instance in which there
was a whole lot of prostitution going on
in one of these golf jackets and it
emerged and it struck me that
essentially look
you want to figure out that the two most
powerful incentives that you can use to
persuade uh at least men
uh are gonna be money and sex right and
so a lobbyist who can figure out how to
provide sex to somebody in a way that
they get away with it that their spouse
is none the wiser and all of that has a
very powerful tool you know we could
figure out what the value the equivalent
value is in money and it's very large
right so anyway the point is corruption
isn't about bribery bribery is aversion
right and uh in any case uh what i would
say is
you have to instantiate the system that
uh the corruption of the system in terms
of the incentives what incentives
whatever incentives persuade people it
will include that full set right and
unless you're looking at that full set
then you will only have a partial
picture of why people do what they do so
you know the the authors there
um are arguing uh about financial
incentives and desmond is saying maybe
it's not
limited to financial incentives and
you're right they're the same story the
question is how narrowly are you zoomed
in right incentives persuade people
ultimately all of that stuff is driven
by
a system built to put your genes into
the future which none of these people
are talking about
right yes bribery is proximate to gene
spreading and gene spreading is now
crazy because lots of people are engaged
in
regulating their own production of
offspring and so they're interrupting
the very process that would unfold you
know that their extra power would give
them extra reproductive opportunities
which they're now not using for
reproduction right but nonetheless um
in what way will people be persuaded
every way that they can right right oh
that's great
okay one last thing and then we'll uh
then we'll go on to the q a which we
encourage i encourage you to ask
questions for uh were we gonna were we
thinking about having a drink for the q
a
yes that was your idea you're acting
like i just proposed that i'm
i have it all set up the question is
do i break it out now or do we wait for
the q a i think i think we wait for the
q a yes where okay see
wow okay
i had no idea clearly
actually i'm not i'm i'm not i'm not
that good an actor um
i can do impressions though yes you can
surprisingly well
um
okay so i have on this show and
elsewhere uh talked about the comic
bookification of of american culture and
specifically i've talked about um it's
seeming like uh millennials
um
who are awoke have a particular tendency
to imagine the world into purely good
and purely evil and you know they see
anyone they disagree with is a super
villain and they see their their heroes
as actual superheroes and it's it's very
unnuanced it's very black and white it's
very unhelpful um but while i was
reading desmond's book this week i was
reminded because he he quotes um him
of this quotation from solzhenitsyn i've
mentioned social nets in the past we
read some from his essay live not by
lies
when we were also um
gosh that was back in october 2020. um
but as i've mentioned here before i was
lucky
to
end up in a class on sultanate son and
kundera in my very first quarter of
college when i was a literature major
uh and i read much of the gulag the
google archipelago at that point i had
never i'd read a bunch of dostoevsky and
tolstoy and such in high school um but
i'd never i'd never even heard of the
gula grasol chinese
i might have heard of gulags but i never
heard of this book um
and
here is a quote from the gulag that
feels to me that it's encompassing of a
lot of what we've talked about today
and also relates very much to this idea
that i have of the comic bookification
of of thinking
if only it were all so simple he says if
only there were evil people somewhere
insidiously committing evil deeds and it
were necessary only to separate them
from the rest of us and destroy them
but the line dividing good and evil cuts
through the heart of every human being
and who is willing to destroy a piece of
his own heart
yeah that's beautiful i've heard
jordan peterson refer to this very thing
um and it's it's an important uh an
important insight it is uh the epitome
of hubris to imagine
uh that
you aren't capable of things that you
have not yet done
um and i guess uh the opposite of hubris
there would be um underestimating
yourself if it's um that you imagine
yourself not capable of positive things
that you have not yet done simply
because you haven't done them
uh we can all hope uh to be our you know
our best angels
um
but
uh
no one is pure in either direction uh
there is there are some
there are some
people who approach monstrosity and
there are people who some people who
approach sainthood but they are
extraordinarily rare
and mostly that's done in retrospect
with
by mythologizing their stories yeah
that's right that's that's actually
right um once you
once you start interacting with the uh
the actual day-to-day of most people you
find that the monsters also like
salad
[Laughter]
and uh the saints um
were quick to anger and uh and and
yelled at dogs in the street or
something you know uh you know i i i
don't have anyone in particular in mind
here but that you know we all have we
all have failings and uh even the
monsters are actually human and that
doesn't mean that we ought to be you
know uh forgiving of their monstrosities
but it is a uh
it is a
huge and tragic error to see in each
other super villains and superheroes
instead of humans with whom we can
sit down and talk for the most part
you're not claiming you can recognize a
villain by the fact that they like salad
right
i mean i'd be cool and i would give up
salad if we could arrange a situation
like that but
you make a good salad though so i don't
think i don't think we should do that
but even still it would be a small price
to pay
yeah i was oh boy now i i think i'm glad
i picked salad because there's a lot of
things i could have picked but now i'd
be just dealing with this forever
dodging and weaving around like no it's
not like that it's not oh boy yeah but
you know salad yes right
it's just it's hard i don't know i'm
just gonna say it's hard to hate on
salad but
it's hard to hate on so there's you're
gonna be remembered for that
indeed
all right um well we're we are uh i
think yeah just about done uh this was
episode 121
of the dark horse live stream we will be
back
next week i think at the normal time
zachary
uh and there are in the next in the
upcoming months there are going to be
some day changes uh uh yeah but uh but
we will keep on we will keep on coming
in part because we had understood before
i ever read desmet's words here
that one of the things that's important
to do when you see
that there is a narrative that is taking
over many people's brains and it does
not feel right is to is to speak and so
we will keep doing that and we are
grateful that you are here to hear us
and um grateful for the stories that you
share with us as well oh yeah so
they are they are extraordinary and you
know keep them coming apologies that we
don't respond to too many of them but we
really do appreciate hearing from you
what you all are experiencing
okay
you're looking at me like i'm crazy
i know better okay so you can ask
questions uh starting probably an hour
ago but um now at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com for a q a
uh logistical questions go to
darkhorsemodder.gmail.com
find us on our patreons find us on my
find me on my subs deck at natural
selections
go check out hunter gatherers guide
either in the english or soon to be the
spanish or french editions and
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside and achieve
greatness
[Music]